let's go to
the difference between uh theoretical
computer science and software
engineering
or um i don't know if you draw a
distinction but if we look into this
computer world now
is there a difference between theory
things you can say
formally and the pragmatic
implementation of that theory into
actual systems that people use yeah
which i
i guess will call software engineering
so you know the engineer
they're obsessed with the domain of well
what do you want to accomplish and who
are you accomplishing it for
so they live in the world of people if
they're good engineers and they say okay
what's the experience
uh you know how are we going to use this
why are we going to do this
what's the commercial application what's
the non-commercial application
and you collect all these business
requirements and
once you've done all of that the better
job you do the more self-evident it is
of how do we apply the toys and tools of
computer science and other such things
to actually resolve that
and you know the point of theoretical
computer science from
the software engineering domain is it
can tell you kind of where your guard
rails are it won't
make perfect programs and there's no
such thing as that
but rather it can give you a good notion
and sense that your program
has some desirable properties like it
maybe it'll you can prove that it can
terminate if you're dealing with total
programs or
maybe you can prove you'll never have a
buffer overflow or you know you'll
won't divide by zero somewhere or
something like that you know some
event won't occur that'll cause a
catastrophic failure in your system
but there's always this combinatorial
explosion between what you can test
and think about and what you can
actually code
so the stuff on the left-hand side lives
in a different cardinality a different
universe there's something significantly
larger there
and the tools on the right-hand side you
know we have property-based testing and
these sat solvers we have all this great
stuff here in formal methods lan and
computer science theory land but there's
only a small subset of things that they
actually
give you good answers about so the
balance of the two things is basically
saying well
what do you care about and what are you
okay throwing away that's the art of
engineering
and building these types of things so
you know cryptocurrencies we deal with
these complex distributed systems that
have cryptography and game theory
and byzantine actors so the balance
there is saying okay what
can't fail in that system and that's the
kind of stuff that you want to apply
as heavy a tool set as you can because
when that stuff fails
you either have a loss of billions of
dollars privacy or
potentially even life depending on how
these systems get adopted
but then other things you know what can
fail is it okay if the block doesn't get
made
you know every now and then is it okay
if your latency goes up or
your your network suddenly becomes
asynchronous and you know you disconnect
from it you have to restart the computer
or something like that
that's probably okay it's an
inconvenience and burden to the user
and if you actually try to chase that
tail you'll end up spending 10 years
chasing phantoms and ghosts meanwhile
the whole world moves on so it's really
figuring out those balance of the two
and what's really beautiful is that the
the formal methods tools have gotten so
much better
over the last 20 years in particular
mostly because of incredibly high
investments from microsoft and google
and
big universities because these guys are
building these
gargantuan systems if you look at the
googleplex or what amazon has or others
and they have so much value so many
users so many things going on and
no person can keep that in their head
and so
you're talking about systems may have 10
million lines of code
15 million lines of code millions of
nodes connecting
faulty processes happening all the time
hackers breaking in on a regular basis
so when you're trying to model all that
trying to ask yourself
what formal guarantees and properties
can i get to simplify this system as
much as possible
so instead of the applications the
formal method is slowing you down in
many cases it actually
massively reduces your debugging time
and your ability to find where errors
occur
in some cases you can't find where
errors occur inside these massive
concurrent systems
and you say well where are
cryptocurrencies going we're talking
about just the same thing
but we're talking about a much more
hostile operating environment
where instead of it running at a
pristine data center in california
somewhere
it's running on your cell phone it's
running on your mom's phone it's running
your dad's phone it's running
on you know some computer in mongolia
that may have good internet
on tuesday but not any other day so when
you live in that kind of environment you
really do need to think carefully about
a whole new class of protocols
and then you need to think carefully
about a whole new class of tools and
techniques to test
the reliability of those systems and you
need to separate the world and say
what is high assurance and cannot fail
because if it fails
people lose money and what is low
insurance and it's okay
if that falls apart the other thing i'll
mention is there perverse financial
incentives in our industry
because the reality is when something
blows up the people who built those
things
that blow up usually get paid up front
so what they're focusing on is time to
market
speed to market and getting tokens out
and getting them
liquid me and then people come in they
buy it but if there's a nissian bug in
some d5 protocol it'll probably
be discovered six months later or
something like that it blows up who
suffers
the users they already got the people
that created that already got paid
exactly that's why you pay the guy who
makes the brake software for your train
last and you make sure he rides the
train every day
you